SPEAKER: Access control
capability in Security Command
Center allows organization
administrators
to grant fine-grained
access to the assets
and findings surfaced in
Security Command Center.
This feature is relevant
for many use cases,
including sensitive
applications or compliance
regimes that require
strict access controls,
as it lets you isolate
Cloud resources
and restrict employee
access to only those they
need to do their jobs.
Access control at the
folder and project level
is available to Security Command
Center Premium customers.
In this video, we'll
walk through how
to grant granular access
control to assets and findings
in your organization,
and demonstrate
the experience from the
end user's perspective.
Starting in the Organization
view of the Security Command
Center, you can see this
example organization
has thousands of assets.
And similarly, it
has many findings,
rather than providing
organization-wide permissions.
Administrators can
use access control
to limit the View or Edit
permissions in Security Command
Center to specific
folders and projects.
We'll now show
how to grant users
access to specific
folders or projects
in Security Command Center
using the Cloud Console.
In the Project
Selector dropdown,
choose the project or
folder to which you would
like to provide scoped access.
In this case, we're
selecting a project.
Then, head to the
IAM landing page,
which you can find with the
left-hand navigation menu.
Search for the user's email
address, and click to edit.
Then add the Security
Center Admin Editor, Viewer,
or one of the many additional
Security Center roles
based on your user's needs.
Then click Save.
The permissions are now
applied and live for your user.
Now, let's switch over to
view the console logged
in as the user.
As you can see,
when the user tries
to access Security Command
Center for the organization
itself, they will get a
Permission Denied error
because they do not have
permissions at the organization
level.
Using the Project
dropdown, we'll
select the target project
to which they were granted
Security Command Center access.
We'll now see Security
Command Center
is scoped to the
specific project,
including only the assets and
findings that are associated
with the project.
For example, by
selecting the Assets tab,
we can now see that
the number of assets
has decreased from
the Organization
view we saw earlier, as now,
these are only the assets that
reside within this project.
When looking at
projects, we can only
see the specific project and not
others within the organization.
We'll click on a specific
asset, such as this bucket,
to expand the asset details.
Take note of the
new Canonical Name
field, which contains the
asset's actual parent project
ID and its name.
Now, let's head to
the Findings tab.
Again, we can only
see findings that
are associated with the assets
contained in this project,
rather than the
organization-wide findings.
Note-- if we had shared
access at the folder level,
we would be able to see
assets and findings associated
with all projects
within that folder.
Just as we saw earlier
in the Assets tab,
we can see that the
details for a finding
includes the new Canonical
Name field, which
identifies the parent project
associated with the finding.
All functionality
across dashboards
is scoped as per the
access controls defined.
For example, in
the Overview tab,
we continue to see the charts
and reports for findings
within the scope
of this project.
And we also see only
the vulnerabilities
associated with this project.
The Settings page, however,
does require organization level
permissions in order to
be viewed and edited.
Because Security Command
Center settings always
apply to the entire
organization.
Congratulations.
You're now equipped to use
Access Control in Security
Command Center to
restrict users,
to manage assets and findings
within an assigned scope.
[MUSIC PLAYING]